全台灣做股票主力在賣鈔
在賣鈔
外資也賣
我們上個禮拜講
只有投信在買
不是外資不是要認錯嗎
怎麼還是偷賣
外資他都買台子期賣現股
之前在做套利
不過最近他的現股
這個也在出貨了
台子期也在賣
所以這個要小心
那投信之前都投信買
現在連投信也在賣
因為我們上禮拜有分析
其實投信是唯一籌碼裡面
他還勇敢站在買方的
對 因為有人在低檔
買了一堆0050、0056
投信他避險去買點股票
對 好講 講到我
好 不過他們這些人
我看最近他們可能買不下去了
是
另外中石戶
中石戶就是主力扣掉三大法人
中石戶也在賣
只有一個人做多
誰
閃戶
只有閃戶做多
不過閃戶做多
我們籌碼我們要偏空看待
是
所以昨天是五大接空
五大接空
結果今天一開盤開高就殺低
就殺低
所以看來五大接空的殺傷力非同小可
對
但是籌碼其實有意向對不對
雖然五大接空
但是這一次台灣不但防疫第一
國家之光
連我們的台股都是國家之光
對 我們來看一下這個
台股某一档股票
这档股票我们都来讲一下
小哥你手都抖了你
实在太强了我帮你拿
这档股票先不要讲他是谁
免得外资对他有提防
这档股票我们看他本土券商
我把这十年来
这十年来区间获利前十名的本土券商
区间获利前十名的券商列出来
只有一个外国人
新加坡瑞盈
新加坡商瑞盈
其他都是台灣人
他不一定是外國人
他可能是台灣有人
入籍新加坡籍之後
在那邊操作
有道理
可能是台中人
因為你看
這個幾乎都是台中彰化的分點
其中第一名叫趙鋒入港
他這十年來賺了6億多
厲害
他賺的錢誰賠的呢
我們看第一名賠的叫摩根大通
賠516
第二名元富
之後還有香港上海會風
台湾汇立港商野村
台湾摩根史丹利
后面还一堆啊
小哥
这张就是我们的骄傲啊
加一加
这个我们叫做本土义和团
本土义和团
本土小钢炮
对上外资长枪
对上八国联军
八国联军
把他们杀的这个
对 不是义和团
不是义和团
对
不能讲义和团
义和团是输的
我们厉害的不是义和团
对对对
好
那这个外资呢
其实在交易上
其实都做得没有很好
没有很好
我们来看这个
昨天很红的那两股票
没有很好我们听他的干嘛
一天大晚都在报外资
对啊 很多人都看外资
其实你看完这段节目之后
看完之后
你可能就不想追外资了
就外资
对不对
肉脚
不好用
对
我们要看中石户
好用
台湾的比较好用厉害好好来看这个华星科你看他昨天涨停喔可是外資呢 其實有沒有看到這外資其實很短啊 什麼
很短線
外資沒有 都是長的啦
對
他也有短的
真的嗎
有短的
我以前聽到外資都是長的啊
都是長的喔 沒有 外資有短的
喔 外資有短的
小哥看的比較多啦
我看比較多
對
我真的看滿多的
我可以跟你講個笑話
好
真的
那笑话是这样子
我有一次去夏威夷
对 夏威夷
对 度蜜月的时候去夏威夷
夏威夷的时候刚好在上厕所
对
隔壁两个老外
上厕所不小心瞄了
上面有刺青
老外上面有刺青
写WA
那里有刺青就对了
那里有刺青
哇 我就哇
WA就是哇
对 我就哇
我说哇 你这刺青
哇 哇
问他什么意思
他说哇
不好意思
他就把它弄長一點給我看
叫Welcome to America
歡迎來到美國
所以其實外資
平常看的時候是短的
有的是短的 有的是長的
那小哥你沒有反拉一些給他看嗎
Welcome to Taiwan之類的
外資它很短線
所以很短線的股票
很容易怎麼樣
很容易今天搶了
明天就弱了
没当头
今天想明天落
那这张股票呢
都是什么要买
都是散户在买
所以散户它还是有发挥功效
对 散户最近把它买上来
对 只是持久力比较差一点
这种散户买上来的
后面都要很小心
对啊
那我们再来看这个台湾之光
台积电
台积电 富国神机
这很厉害喔
对 富国神机呢
它在什么时候这个外资大卖呢
你看一下 在低点的时候外资大卖
真的耶
这不是卖错了吗
外资落脚
对啊
不过我必须说
因为也有认识一些台积电的人
他们对自己公司其实没有很乐观
他们对景气的看法
其实跟慕华哥会差不多觉得
其实景气可能有很大的衰退
可是没有想到股价就这样上去了
对 那他们其实没有很乐观
在低档台湾人中食物还是在买
厉害耶
厉害 他们抄底
中食物抄底
然後閃戶是一路買啊
閃戶一路買
閃戶也厲害啊
閃戶高檔買低檔也買
閃戶都在買
存股嘛 一直存一直存
這個是一種情感
一種情感
對 國家之光
那這個台義燕在那天開法書
開完之後外資買6萬張
回補 認錯回補
然後中時務在那一天
很冷的道給他
厲害吧 小哥整介
因为很多人手上有台积电
我们当然要跟着中石户
不能跟外资
外资的单不能跟
因为外资他们比的是相对绩效
他们不是比说我今天赔多少赚多少
不是
他比我比老王赚多少还是赔多少
比隔壁老王
跟隔壁的外资比
他们比的相对绩效
主要是比排名
只要排名高就可以了那外資常常追高沙地啊你比如說我們看友達友在这个高档在这个高档外资继续追是然后中石物在这个高档大卖
对
大卖给他
散户高档有卖
现在跌下来散户又买
所以这档呢
散户做得还不错
这档呢
散户在高档有卖
值得称赞的对不对
对
可能因为是他啦
散户真的不敢报太久
所以我们大部分
看散户
散户有时候做得不错
那外资大部分都做得蛮差的
因为散户其实会有经验值
因为有的股票会有所谓的credit
所以你有时候买它
散户也学聪明了
知道不要搞太久
好 不要搞太久
好 我们再看鸿海
鸿海也是很多散户爱的股票
可是鸿海我们看
在高点的时候外资拼命追
是
中食物拼命到
对
散户也到给外资
那等到第一档下来的时候
外资就到货
所以外资追高杀低
所以这一党也是本土资金
大胜外资
就是土炮对洋炮
土炮胜对不对
对
每次都是土炮胜
这一党我们同事非常多人在问
你说这党
那个鸿海
当然啦
鸿海我是觉得你不要碰他
不是
现在我们土炮都赢了
然后你还是觉得不要碰他
这一党从我们节目开播两年来
郭董已经开始买他自己的股票了
买了4000张了
所以莫华哥觉得还是不要碰吗
没有 上一次郭董要连买六个月
要连买六个月股票才涨上去
你的意思是现在开始买
至少要等半年
上一次经验就那样
就刚刚小哥那一波
就拉上去最高那一波
就是郭董先前买了半年之后
就拉上去
对 这边买了以后拉上去
对 他总共买了六个月
所以布局要半年
是这个意思
那现在刚开始买
对 所以你就往后推半年
就是红海的买点
跟著郭董存股
非常明確
小哥你要拿出一些例子來
就是我們有給外資一點顏色瞧瞧
顏色瞧瞧
我們來看一下這個人保
好 人保大股票
對 各位看一下
這個低點呢
低點都是他在賣的
外資在賣
外資在賣 這邊
就這樣把低點的地方賣掉了
然後中石戶在賣
不过最近可能要小心一点
因为最近的中食物转为卖超
只有昨天有稍微买一点
不过这个长时间看起来再卖
因为我也听说他们内部人有讲
说其实订单很满
只是出货有点状况
因为断链的问题
断链
对 所以订单是好的
很乐观 但是出不了货
所以之后应该很多产业都有这个问题
都有这个问题
会有断链的问题
所以订单的乐观不是真的乐观
要注意
好 接下来我们看第二档
世界先进
也算大股票
也大股票
外资也是砍在低点
好奇怪 为什么
外资都最高杀低
然后中食物也是买在低点
不过最近弹上来之后
最近中食物也在出了
要小心了
除了这两个要小心以外
我们来讲正在买的
正在买
这个是历史验证
历史验证
就是本土的资金真的远胜外资远胜外资好我們來看一下这个中书也是胜外资的合润企业最近正在买哎哟
合润
各位看一下
中书最近在买
对
可是外资在到货
所以小哥我
我懂暗号了
不要去追
你可以观察就好
合润企业我们都会想说
它租车的嘛
租车应该最近声音应该很差
因为大家都不敢出去玩
本来呢 零确诊就是有了一线生机嘛
但是最近因为你知道军舰事件
所以大家就害怕起来
它应该伤害很大才对
它应该很大
可是我们看它其实上个月的YY还正的
M1还增加21%
厉害喔
代表有些人不敢坐车
宁愿租车
这也是一个商机
租车比较安全嘛
但总之筹码面上它现在是在转强
没错
那除了这以外呢
我们再看一下
这个最近油价跌嘛
油价点就容易上瘦下肥
就是上油比较瘦一点
这个利润比较少
下油因为成本变便宜了
所以像这个长芯化工
外资也是砍在低点
真的很妙
到现在还在砍
可是本土法文在这边
中石户就一路的大买
这边差好多
买很多
这个的话我们观众朋友可以注意了
我们可以来留意说
到底这个本土资金
是不是买了之后
股价后续表现怎么样
因为这边要讲
我们不是说
今天小哥帮你筛出来以后
就是叫你买
千万不要这样想
是在教你判断
看看是不是中时户买
外资买
反而中时户是赢的
好 我们再来看下一档
那这一档呢
也是实施库藏股
它有实施库藏股
后升
那实施库藏股的分点呢
这个在永丰金的某分点
也是关键分点
关键分点
那关键分点各位看一下这个底部呢
这个底部的时候
其实关键分点买很多
中石户也买很多
这太戏剧性了吧
对
外资卖那么大
对 外资都砍在低点
中石户买在低点
买这么多
那现在弹起来之后
中石户继续买
因为它库长股嘛
所以库长股继续买超
好
这就符合小哥讲的
公司自己的大股东是很看好的
但是外资搞不好不懂他们的好在哪里
对
那这个它有一些的产业
跟石油有点关系
也算石油的下油
也算是受惠于说油价下跌的话
油价下跌
它可以可能成本减轻
好 希望大家来观察一下
小哥我们来看看
你的预测准不准确
我们来看它之后的股价状况
对 总看着就好
不要跟了 不要追
就不是叫大家买
大家做做功课好不好
如果觉得小哥这样
方法非常适用的话
你是一辈子受用
那慕华哥怎么看呢
好 那土洋对座
最近有一档股票
非常值得密切观察
一档
没有推荐
只要大家观察
对 其实大家观察
大家真的要记得看节目
不是叫你买股票
要学方法
就是说我们观察这一波
到底外资会不会胜出
今年外资买股票
买最用力的一档股票
当然不是说只有这档股票
外资其实也买蛮多股票
但这档它是买得非常用力
这档股票叫做智邦
哎哟